in the video on the second law of
thermodynamics i talk about how the
entropy of the universe is constantly
increasing that it's not going to
decrease and another way of thinking
about it is is that the energy in the
universe more and more of it is going
towards entropy it's becoming less and
less useful
and the argument that i use even in our
everyday i talk about hey while i'm
making this video my body is generating
heat and that heat is leading to entropy
it's leading to more entropy in the
universe and a reasonable question is
how does heat lead to entropy and
remember heat is a transfer a transfer
of thermal energy and entropy this is a
state of the system it's the number of
it's it's the it's it's a it's the
amount of disorder we have it's the
number of states that a system could
actually take on so let's have an
example here let's say assume that this
is an ideal closed system this little
white square here and these molecules
are bouncing around with some
temperature so they have some average
kinetic energy each molecule will be
doing different things and i always draw
it as this translational kinetic energy
but they could be rotating and
oscillating and doing all sorts of other
things so they could be they could be
doing other things as well but the
translational kinetic energy is a little
bit easier to actually visualize but now
let's transfer some heat into the system
so
we have a transfer of thermal energy
which we call heat
let me pick a color for that i will use
orange and we use the letter q to denote
heat so we have a heat transfer coming
into this and then because of this the
temperature of this system goes up the
average kinetic energy goes up these
things start bouncing around with more
with more momentum with more velocity so
why does this system have entropy you
might say well look you know there's
they have the same number of molecules
i have the same amount of volume i'm
looking at a two-dimensional looks like
area but we can imagine the same amount
of volume that it's filling up it feels
like there's the same number of places
that the actual molecules could be
but our state is not dictated purely by
position not purely by where the
different things are it's the state is
everything about the system that you
could use to predict what's going to
happen next to the system so the state
also includes the various velocities of
these particles so you when you have a
higher temperature you have a larger
number of potential velocities that you
might be able to actually take on and
also when you have this higher kinetic
energy remember all of these all of
these molecules they at the end of the
day they're you know they they're made
up of atoms that have nuclei and they
have electrons buzzing around them and
as they if they don't have much kinetic
energy they might not be able to get too
close so let's say this is the outer
electrons of one i'll just say atom and
let's say that this is another one right
over here if they're going with only a
reasonable kinetic energy
if they go with a reasonable kinetic
energy they might be able to get maybe
they're they're going to be able to get
that close but if they if they were
running if they were hitting each other
much faster they might be able to get a
little bit closer they might they might
they kind of might kind of smush into
each other if you imagine kind of two
balls hitting each other much faster
they're going to push on each other a
little bit harder and so there's
actually more possible states you can
take on when you have higher kinetic
energy so this was this is you know
these things came in really really fast
and smooshed into each other while these
were nice and polite and came in at a
nice gentle at a nice gentle velocity so
you can actually even have more
positional states more more different
configurations in three-dimensional
space so that's why heat is actually
leading to entropy now i know what some
of you might be saying well heat doesn't
only heat doesn't only cause disorder in
fact heat can be used to do work in fact
that's the whole basis in fact a lot of
the basis of the industrial revolution
steam engines combustion engines the
combustion engine in your car that uses
heat uses a combustion reaction to to
expand to expand to push up a piston
which is used to do actual work and that
is act that is of course true and over
here we have an example of that
happening so i have some i have some
molecules in here buzzing around with
some temperature and then i'm going to
apply i'm going to add some heat to the
system
so let's add some
let's add some heat to the system and in
this system i don't have just a closed
boundary these things start buzzing
around more they can take on more states
and all of that type of thing but they
can also use to expand the container so
what we see happening here is they push
this piston they push this piston open
you actually have work
you actually do work in a different
color you actually have work being done
you actually and i'll do it smaller you
actually have some work being done and
how is that work being done well as
these things bounce around
and we're talking about a lot of
molecules every now and then one of
these molecules is going to bump there
and then bounce off but that's going to
provide some force for a very small
amount of time that's going to push it
up a little bit and but you have so many
of these molecules do it i've only drawn
a handful of them but in any real
thermodynamic system you're going to be
talking about many you know many
millions and millions and millions
you're talking about things on the
multiples of avogadro's number number of
molecules and so at any given moment a
lot of them are going to be bouncing
right off of this thing they're going to
be doing work they're going to be
pushing they're going to be displacing
this piston in the direction of the
force or part a component of their force
is going to be pushing this piston
actually up and doing work
but no
no heat based i guess you could say
system or engine can be 100 efficient so
some of this can be used to do work but
a lot of it is going to be used to add
to the disorder of the system to
increase the number of states that the
system could take on one way to think
about it then this has always helped me
is heat heat is transfer of thermal
energy that happens at the boundary of
the system this heat could be you know
maybe there's a
maybe there's a flame down here and at
the boundaries this thing might be able
to if this wasn't a fully closed system
it could release heat at the boundaries
of the system but within the system the
the the heat is just leading the
increased thermal energy is just leading
to more entropy now work also happens at
the boundary of the system so up here
there's probably some heat being
released but it's also able to do work
so heat and work these are happening at
the boundaries of the system but a lot
of that energy goes into the inside of
the system and that is just things are
just going to you know like a big mosh
pit these things are going to run into
each other much faster and way more
states that they could take on and so
that's why when i talk about you know if
i move around and i'm walking on the
floor just the friction the carpet is
going to generate heat that's going to
contribute to entropy in the universe
just me existing the cellular processes
in my body they generate heat it
increases the entropy of the universe
that makes the the total energy of the
universe less useful
that's why it's happening